but here's where all comes together man
here let's check this out this meteorite
gun sales surged up to one hundred and
forty five percent in June
smashing all-time record you got a lot
of people don't I use guns who got guns
now yeah that makes me nervous it's a
good point
look at that look that couple in st.
Louis it's like listen man I've been to
arrange twice and I've taken one
training course with the New Jersey
Police Department long time ago as part
of a story I was working on and they and
they walked me up through all these
different handguns and I would not ever
claim that I could properly you know so
I'm still looking to like what we got to
do to make sure we're trained and
they're gonna be you know going to the
range and setting all these things up
but you got a lot of people we're gonna
buy it and be like point and shoot huh
yeah someone's gonna be scared from all
these stories and it's gonna be like
some know people are scared well are
scared they're they already are they're
already seeing people getting pulled out
of their cars getting shot at for simply
being in your car you can get shot at
you see a crowd there's a chance they're
gonna just shoot you I I don't blame
them for just plowing through people now
it's like what what do you got back
there there people killed
there's a handful of scenarios one a
group of actual peaceful protesters yeah
art hippie dancing in the street and a
cards goes boom right stroke right
through them exactly and then when they
get arrested they cite provo and they
say we get it yep in fear for their life
because these people have done this or
you get a group of these protesters
marching through a neighborhood like we
saw in st. Louis only this time the lady
who doesn't use a gun who got her finger
on the trigger and is waving at people
panics and didn't have any other night
yeah exactly it's a really worried and
that's when it goes it goes crazy but
that's the tension that everyone's
feeling oh yeah because everybody feels
it yeah everyone's like I don't want to
piss anyone off I'm just trying to live
my life can we you know you know like
when you're winding up like those
Springs call that it's like no no it's
like I said like a clock you win the
Groton ssin this the spring is actually
just a strip of metal that gets spun
tighter and then ice spins a torsion
springs out it's going it can't get any
tighter because it's compressed complete
that's what it feels like that's what
I'm that's what I'm feeling like what
more could possibly happen to give
anyone more anxiety I got this I got
this aliens yeah no I think I think
people
like Oh finally something we can unify
against that right yeah well maybe I
don't know if they're good or bad but I
think people snap that's what we're
seeing people snapping yeah people are
scared you know and I think right a
point where the dominoes have all been
set up and then all it takes is one
little flick it's true dominoes go down
and one by one a chain of events will
happen that will start occurring that
can't be stopped
yep and I think maybe we're already
there that's what we're feeling well you
said it earlier yeah that kind of
happening you know that though that meme
where there's like a little tiny thing
and he taps it and then knocks over a
bigger bigger you tablet and a bigger
tablet and it scales up to a massive you
know talking about I haven't seen a meme
but I've seen the art thing it's like
they do and it's it's like a freaking
30-foot tall Domino yeah like a really
tiny one that and then it grows there's
a meme about it where it's like one tiny
action result in one really really crazy
thing like what was the most recent one
this this dollar bill looks funny
at that store in Minneapolis and then
the end result is like the entire oh
right yeah exactly that's exactly it
well the other one is yeah the bat soup
tries to take a taste
yep yeah the the dollar the dollar bill
thing yeah one counterfeit bill one guy
saw it's like butterfly effect man this
dudes like this twenty don't look right
and he calls the cops and now here we
are everything's in cast but you know
it's it's it seems to me like the
dominoes have been stacked up for a long
time
well it's election year so they really
have to kick it up a notch this is
different this is what it would it what
did would assertive itch tweet he says
the first time in my life that the
fourth of July has been canceled yeah it
was pretty insane that scares me the
most because who's gonna who's gonna say
who's gonna say okay we won't deliver at
the 4th of July yeah that's fine I'll do
nothing like it's literally a day where
we tell the government to eff off it's
like the holidays literally based upon
the day when Americans were like f you
to the to the monarch that's good point
and so now they're the government saying
nobody celebrate that day we're telling
the government to shut off unless you're
antiva going to the gettysburg
historical cemetery oh I got it I got it
burn Oh
what you got here here's here's Andrew
Cuomo this New Yorkers must comply with
social distancing and wear masks don't
risk your life don't risk someone else's
life wear a mask and over 40% of the
deaths in New York City were from people
he shoved into nursing homes here's what
I said
NYC occupation exempt it of course yeah
cortico is the or protesting do we do
actually have that
yeah cops clash with NYC Occupy City
Hall protesters after City Council vote
and leave this this is amazing
three people were taken to custody when
accused yada yada after a heated
standoff cops back down allowing the
occupation to continue thereafter cops
at 300 protesters spent the better part
of the morning cheering clapping and
toasting their accomplishments with blue
Solo cups of champagne brought to the
encampment after the NYPD budget was
slashed and then I love it Acacio Cortes
what did she say 1 billion is not enough
1 billion well we say defund the police
I mean defund the police what does that
mean though did that shut no money so
abolish you mean yeah
you don't mean to defund you mean
abolish yeah stupid I think these people
are I my personal opinion is the first
thing they need to do is get rid of the
police because then the the fight on the
street becomes ideological forcing
people to choose sides the biggest
obstacle for the far left in their
acceleration Espeland is the police who
are neutral their government their
establishment but they're not
ideological now they can try and argue
the police are and many of them are but
when it comes to pro-trump
Mogga proud boy whatever and an tyfa far
laughed progressive the police are not a
part of either these tribes
they're standing in a way as a whole
which mean right very what's supposed to
happen is when the the two tribes clash
the police break it up push everyone
apart make arrests not always so how do
you how do you get it so that you can
have your full-on war the left needs to
give it to the police
it's a good point and they're doing it
once the police are abolished
demoralized or gone then you're gonna
see like weren't you telling me this the
other day that a bunch of
joining militias and stuff yep they're
facts they're they're factional izing
whatever the word would be mm-hmm
they're they're joining so then once the
place are gone now the American people
are torn between which side is the lid
is the legitimate side and it goes all
the way to the top is it Joe Biden or
Donald Trump and yet we have these their
protest calling and asking for police
escorts to keep them safe yeah yeah as
they asked to do and while they
protested funding they're clearly
cheating they're clearly not playing by
any legitimate rule they're just trying
to manipulate I think most of them are
just dumb I think most of them are just
like whatever following whatever yeah so
when someone is cool opens a gate to
private property they walk in like yeah
this is we can be here or not they have
no idea you know it's like I think about
the conversations I have on Facebook
with people and it's really funny you
can make a vague statement and then
someone makes a million-one assumptions
about what they think you're talking
about and it's always some weird
high-level political it's like you could
pose something like that's this is the
joke about Twitter it's like man I love
pancakes why do you hate waffles yep
like there's an assumption people make
they just want it to be the fight yeah I
I'm sick of it man I on Facebook too
it's just like that's what it feels like
you can't say anything without I mean
even on Twitter it doesn't matter social
media in general you say anything people
just they take it and fit it into their
narrative look at the bottom line of how
they can be upset about the narrative
that they've placed on it and then
scream at you for that and it's like
well you're the one who you're the one
who made it racist you're the one who's
applying your rules of all whatever it's
not necessarily racist it's PC culture
in general you know thank you're the one
who are is twisting it into that I told
you about bugs bunny ink on text it's
basically that that famous episode of
you know Looney Tunes where Daffy is
like it's rabbit season and bugs like
it's duck season and they go back and
forth and then finally Bugs Bunny
switches and says it's rabbit season
so then Daffy says duck season and then
bug says okay
but basically making your opponent argue
against their own position exactly by
switching I I do this all time and
Facebook
I've actually got people to argue
against black lives matter because
they always want to be fighting and
that's to me that proves they don't
actually care about anything other than
who's my enemy and who's on my side
emotionally compromised but people are
always fighting even the left fighting
themselves it's the weirdest thing like
I'll see someone I'm not gonna name
these people but there's some
high-profile intersection illicit inter
you know and they'll post something and
then the responses are like honey you
are so wrong on this one this is a bad
take not a good look
and then they'll apologize and there's a
back-and-forth like oh I'm so sorry I
don't realize because they're that no
one they're not on anyone's side
it's just they just hate you know they
just want to feel like they have power
over you they're smart you're wrong and
you can really easy easily manipulate
that by saying things and then and then
just making them argue against you know
you can make them argue for Trump it's
very strange and I kid I kid you not
these people clearly don't have a set of
principles they're arguing for or spine
and I think right maybe that's the
difference between the two tribes why it
is there are many liberals who switched
and joined the Trump camp the Democrat
to deplorable Jack Murphy's book I think
it's like 9 million people who voted for
Obama
switchin voted for Trump even some
Bernie supporters and I wonder if it's
because these are people who only have
principle and so they will begrudgingly
accept the problems of Donald Trump
accepting core issues that they think
are important like the Democrats used to
be in favor of immigration controls
border controls helping the the you know
the working class the white
working-class college you know people
throw college degrees but now that now
Olson they're the party of the
internationalist corporation that wants
to outsource China like Bernie Sanders
said in 2015 that open borders was a
coke brothers proposal
now the DNC was against it at the time
right now the DSA has openly endorsed
open borders and it's become a left-wing
thing so if you're someone who stands on
principle you're saying I've always
degree always agree that open borders is
bad I agree with Bernie well now
Bernie's abandoned you right Bernie's
now calling for decriminalizing border
crossings and a moratorium on
deportations so you're like okay well if
I stand on my principles the only person
who's close to what I believe in is
Trump so you can talk about all the
problems but at least he checks some of
the boxes no you have these people on
the Left who it's like they've now a
opted positions that were once held by
right-wing libertarian industrialists my
private platform they say when when all
these social media companies are taking
control of the Commons they used to
fight for they say the Commons are
spaces that must be helped by the public
which includes the town square
ok well now the Town Square has been
taken over by private corporations
well the private corporations have a
right to do what they want they can ban
whoever they want and and it's ok so if
I'm gonna stand on my principles it's
not with the Democrats I've always been
in favor of regulation you know I love
it when they're like Republicans all of
a sudden care about regulation but
they've always hated it I'm like yeah
sure maybe I don't like the Republican
politicians at all well they like
regulation now so don't worry about that
well I don't care I don't I don't care
about I think they're ineffective I
think they're doing nothing but I've
been I've always had upheld the position
that major corporations run amok and we
need a government to to play referee a
bit yeah but now there's no position for
like where liberals used to be unless
you've abandon your principles and just
blindly follow this this new religion of
intersectional ISM there we are I guess
yep there we are with a new with a new
occupation and it's not making shifted
to the other other coasts
yeah escape from LA escape from Seattle
from Seattle to New York yeah I guess so
what happens on the 4th of July nothing
see I saw there was there's one article
going around saying beware of the 4th of
July just I saw I saw some scary
articles that are people are saying like
I've I've like went into this group see
what is about and this is what was being
passed around and it was basically
antifa saying we're gonna go kill white
people and like straight up take people
out on earth that could be propaganda
you're absolutely right you're
absolutely right it could be it could be
propaganda and man exactly I hope it's
propagate like trying to scare people
into thinking and he was gonna go do it
go you know go do something crazy yeah
it's like the are they just trying to
scare people to not go out you know like
don't go out July 4th because they're
gonna they might kill you or is that
just gonna bring more people out because
they're gonna be like bring it on
you see July 4th I see you celebrate you
see what SPD reported as they were
clearing the chest what vehicles with no
license plates driving around as they
were clearing out the camp with what
saw that what yeah mm-hmm no license
plate they don't know who it was but
they knew they had weapons yep scene
armed driving around in vehicles and no
license plates mhm it's scary man antiva
so but you know I guess the question I
have is there a lot of people who keep
saying things like calm down it's not
that bad you're overreacting and stuff
and it's like well okay fine but like
they literally just killed a bunch of
people and well you got to remember
though it's also these are all in cities
that guns are not easy to get or most
people don't have guns easily right
legally Seattle New York it's like it's
not you can't own a gun in New York
you're not allowed to own a gun or you
can you can but you have to jump through
a hundred loops
I think it's together it's actually
similar to New Jersey like there's no
open carry or or concealed gun you can't
walk around the weapon okay okay it's
weird
I don't know I don't know the four rules
I know some things about New York are
easier for purchasing but they're very
very very restrictive right well look
what my point was is like this is where
we're seeing all this stuff happening
we're you know now they they go out to a
smaller place in Idaho and it's like
they made it they made a mistake now
today I'm seeing people are were
protesting in a smaller town and 2,000
people came and and surrounded the black
lives matter movement yelling all lives
matter and they were drowned out the
black lives matter movement where just
like they were served they were the ones
who were surrounded but in in Boise
where there was a big counter protest
the government sided with the left in
Philadelphia the government sided with
the left in in Columbus Ohio the
government sides the left in Virginia
sides with the left are these all
Democrat places no no I mean is Richmond
run by Democrats not sure thanks for
checking out this clip from the Tim cast
IRL podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you